jean-luc giner bonjour bonjour vous êtes
pour c'est que vous connaîtrez pas
encore un homme de théâtre complet vous
êtes à la fois un auteur vous être
comédien metteur en scène directeur de
troupe directeur de théâtre avec le
théâtre du nord-ouest la troupe c'est la
troupe de l'élan nous a créé aussi des
livres sur le terreau de réflexion sur
le théâtre théâtre chrétiens notamment
oui non on en parlera et puis vous allez
être en scène à versailles pendant le
mois molière mois molière qui n'est pas
seulement consacré à molières d'ailleurs
non non non puisque l'on peut lire c'est
un terme générique aux voiles sont
invités à passer françois de me dire que
comme vous le savez un homme
extraordinaire qui a créé s'appuie dieu
merci il est devenu maire qu'un homme de
culture deviennent mères ces craintes
c'est pas tous les ans une richesse
avait sorti aujourd'hui facile quand on
connaît le niveau nos hommes politiques
enfin bref on peut que se féliciter de
ça donc on le fait chaque année
il me confie ce qui rend la direction
genou est trop fort mais des petites
écuries où je les ai monté un peu ce que
ce que l'énergie monsieur ce que je veux
qu est un lieu superbe extraordinaire
avec une acoustique un tout petit peu
difficile mais avec les années je crois
qu'on est arrivé à s'habituer enfin les
comédiens on travaille pour que les
comédiens puissent bien faire passer les
textes c'est un gros travail de
préparation c'est un travail différent
pour pompes pour vous que de jouer dans
dans le théâtre par exemple du
nord-ouest dans la tête que vous
connaissez la caisse au théâtre qui est
fait pour ça aussi c'est un travail un
tout petit peu différent pour une raison
très simple c'est que comme vous le
savez moi je j'essaie de défendre ce que
j'appelle le cadre de l'incarnation est
à dire le théâtre l'homme à l'homme dont
je suis le met en scène deux lentilles
distance donc tout ce qui est archétypes
caricature
je combats ça mais mais mais mais mais
vraiment violemment et là se pose un
problème artistique est assez amusant
c'est que comme il ya un petit écho dans
le truc donc évidemment ça amène une
certaine distance parce que le comédien
doit attendre attendre cela que l'écho
se passe et tout ça sans perdre sa
vérité son père de sa réalité humaine
châtiment si c'est un petit peu
compliqué mais c'est un exercice auquel
tout le monde se prête et puis
finalement on retrouve la vérité la
réalité avec l'accoutumance l'habitude
du lieu il faut en faire comme lisez les
dernières des comédiens qui était un peu
souvent dérangé il faut en faire il faut
faire de ce lieu un ami lui les
contraintes sont parfois bonnes
absolument la première année on a eu
quelques petites quelques petits
problèmes parce que les gens ont sonné
tendez pas bien ok maintenant je crois
que tout le monde entend très bien et
que ça se passe formidablement alors
vous allez essentiellement vous consacre
ainsi que giraudoux ou compte ce mois en
partie ou en partie en tout cas oui il
ya quatre pièces de giraudoux
et la voilà le cantique des cantiques
est une pièce très peu connue de gernot
métier vraiment qui est magnifique et
puis l'impromptu de paris où je jouais
avori table
s'est joué à quelques très bien
et puis vous avez vous aimé créé ma tête
du nord-ouest la folle de chaillot enfin
oui
c'est vrai qu'il ya aussi d une partie
comme ça qui est extrêmement moderne
enfin dans la folle de chaillot
notamment c'est le règne de l'argent
tout à fait à chercher du pétrole
partout heureusement qui est des fous
comme ça où des folles la vie viennent
remettre les eaux à la réalité moi je
suis content parce que on est en train
de redécouvrir giraudoux puisque francis
huster va monter
cc c'est formidable que tout d'un coup
c'est cet auteur qui avait oublié un peu
oublié attaqué pour des bêtises parce
que la dose pendant laquelle il était
que la beauce le complètement faux
totalement faux et quand on a fait cette
intégrale il y avait déjà des textes
rappelé qu'il était même en 44 bien sûr
et morts en 44 et puis il a écrit des
choses absolument magnifique et
notamment sur la guerre de 14 des textes
qui sont d'une force d'une puissance
son texte sur les
expériences de ces guerres c'est quelque
chose de puissant aussi un amoureux de
la littérature allemande à vos relations
entretenues peut-être que c'est la
confusion entre exactement seyfried est
une très grande pièce seulement et ses
romans fin c'était une merveille en tout
cas moi j'étais ravi de pouvoir
le remettre au goût du jour
alors donc ça ça va être ça va être bon
pendant ce mois de versailles donc aux
petites écuries vous même vous avez
consacré votre vie au théâtre
la compagnie de l'élan vous aviez à
peine 18 ans
comment est venue cette vocation
j'étais au lycée janson et puis j'ai un
copain qui étaient là qui dit il
ce que tu veux jouer je n'ai jamais joué
je voulais être romancier
et puis je suis rentré dans la salle y
montaient donges mans il m'avait proposé
joue un petit rôle je suis rentré dans
la salle ça clermont et puis j'ai su
c'est exactement comme une un coup de
foudre en amour ah oui j'ai su que
c'était ça et que toute ma vie je ferai
ça est très vite comme le mont camarades
jouaient sganarelle en fait tout le
monde donnait un petit bond puis
finalement on a plus écouté que moi et
voilà et c'est comme ça que j'ai fait
mon premier spectacle et ensuite un
deuxième puits après la troupe le combat
des troupes alors si vite et parce que
c'était un moyen de liberté dans sa
troupe instrument de liberté formidable
c'est ce que j'essaye de faire au
nord-ouest à dire que vrai les gens ils
peuvent le le soir arrivé chez moi je
les connais pas vous rencontrez un quart
d'heure et au bout d'un quart d'heure je
leur dis d'accord oui c'est vous avez
toujours aimé une programmation qui soit
prêt très
diversifiés si vous voulez j'essaye de
faire ce que moi j'ai mal vécu quand
j'avais été difficile attend au 18 ans
parce que c'est impossible on envoyait
les textes les pièces à tous les
théâtres de paris ont frappé aux portes
avec une énergie une folie mais mais
mais mais complète et puis personne ne
vous répondais et moi je veux être la
personne qui répond et qui dit oui ou
qui dit non mais on en est loin de là
bas marco on discute pas les trucs comme
ça et puis moi je lis les pièces là par
exemple on va une des pièces qui va être
jouée qui s'appelle la confession du
diable qui font qu'on va jouer donc au
moins un molière une pièce de stéphanie
le bail je les ai reçus par la poste
donc on peut encore sans que celui
personnes
puis voir et c'est tout à fait possible
et je lis les pièces
mais c'est un énorme boulot mais ces
voix là et c'est ça que je veux j'ai
voulu éviter
j'ai voulu éviter que mes amis qui ont
la même passion que moi quand j'avais 20
ans que n'est pas perdu eh bien on
puisse ne pas vivre ce que moi j'ai vécu
quand j'étais voilà et puis ce qui s'est
passé c'est que quand tu as en revanche
quand ça a explosé ça a été terrible
parce que tout est tenu en même temps
s'est mis une année on s'est mis à avoir
cinq spectacles en même temps dans cinq
théâtres différend avec les dévoile
annoncé c'est là on à l'école ont collé
des affiches par exemple pour le lan
milo tas de sites universitaires qui
dure un spectacle durée de quatre heures
avec 27 comédiens on allait après tout
la nuit coller des affiches on a connu
vingt mille affiches pour vous donne une
idée du secteur vous êtes tout nous
mêmes voilà on fait tout mais c'est ça
qui est passionnant
qui est passionnant et puis essayer que
le maître mot ne soit pas l'argent ni le
goût du public ce qui est un problème
c'est quelqu'un qui est le gros problème
du taf c'est comme vous le savez je suis
critique donc j'étais à tous les soirs
je vois bien les il faut pas jeter la
pierre aux directeurs ils sont coincés
financièrement et moi j'ai voulu
décoincer ça je veux que la dimension
artistique soit première et puis je veux
aussi qu'on puisse rater
essayez c'est très important je dis
toujours qu'on est ouest voilà il ya les
meilleurs spectacles et les plus mauvais
c'est très très important d'essayer de
rater de tenter de deux voilà comment
voulez-vous on peut pas ça s'improvise
pas c'est bien si on n'a pas une pièce
jouée on sait pas exactement ce que
c'est que le non dit au théâtre par
exemple édito 6 et c'est vrai pour vous
d'ailleurs mais que le tester la chose
la plus importante au monde
bon c'est presque plus important que la
vie en ce sens que au fond quand on est
au théâtre on regarde de l'autre alors
que quand on le croise dans la rue
parfois ligne or c'est exactement ça
c'est à dire que le théâtre vous oblige
à regarder votre frère humain dans sa
réalité sans le fuir je donne un exemple
vous êtes
vous prenez le métro vous avez un clodo
qui est sur le quai vous allez remettre
à 15 mètres vous n'avez pas le regarder
là vous payez votre place pour le voir
vivre et agir vous pouvez pas aller
exactement voulait pas déranger par une
part d un couple qui s'embrasse vous
n'êtes pas dérangé par un meurtre vous
n'êtes pas dérangé par et vous regarder
ça et ça nous permet de voir c'est votre
frère humain qui est en face de vous
votre second vous même est la vraie
lutte aujourd'hui c'est que ce théâtre
n'est plus utilisé avec cette
spécificité là il est utilisé comme
spectacle semaines et non plus comme un
miroir de deux lettres une voie là qu'on
va voir quelque chose et on est un peu
oui juste spectateurs voilà c'est contre
ça vraiment que je peux que je me bats
et j'ai c'est que le théâtre du
nord-ouest soit le terme de l'étape du
lieu de l'incarnation alors le lit de la
carnation d'où vient ce qui est au fond
une de vos combats c'est ce que vous
appelez le théâtre chrétiens debout
comme ça qu'ils sont a priori
très opposées vous qu'est ce que je dois
faire le christ est décevante dans le
théâtre alors il ya un bon livre pas ce
livre et puis un autre qui va sortir
chez bayard qui va s'appeler sans miroir
la société est condamnée à mourir pour
un théâtre un carnet ça va sentir chez
bayard en septembre et le rapport est
très proche c'est que je suis
profondément catholique le père don et
le catholicisme et le théâtre où quelque
chose en commun de très forts qu est
l'incarnation c'est à dire que
c'est si on réfléchit bien c'est
impossible c'est fou d'être catholique
puisque on croit que dieu s'est incarné
dieu pleinement sommes pleinement dieu
en même temps en un instant c'est une
chose impossible à concevoir vraiment et
là j'ai écrit pas mal de bouquins sur
l'arianisme essaiera l'arianisme qui
essaye de dire que jésus est un notre
super fière et non pas le fils de dieu
serpent donc c'est une vraie
interrogation mais nous comédiens quand
on est sur un plateau quand je joue
quand je joue jouvet sur le plateau je
suis ouvert je suis aussi jane eyre
voilà là le philhar est le personnage de
fonds comme si on voulait résumer
exactement mais je ne suis pas la moitié
moitié la moitié nord vous êtes je suis
pleinement l'un est pleinement l'autre
en même temps et ça ça nous permet de
comprendre le mystère de la croix le
théâtre nous permet de comprendre la
réalité cible est tangible du
christianisme de l'essence même de la
spécificité du christianisme quels que
soient les auteurs quel que soit ce que
je valais les dangers de monter et là on
va commencer le mois molière par sa part
ce texte est peut-être le plus beau de
tous qui est le mystère la charité de
jeanne d'arc de pelli on commence par sa
quête une des choses les plus
extraordinaires du monde mais on n'a pas
besoin d'avoir nécessairement des
grandes personnes avec des auteurs dame
comme celle de jeanne s'opposant à au
viet et à madame gervaise il peut y
avoir un éboueur et tout comme dans
giraudoux db les personnages quel est le
regard après quand même pas mal de
belles courses a créé le théâtre vous
disiez tout à l'heure voilà c'est un peu
le rêve du goût du public de règles du
commercial est-ce que vous avez encore
de l'espoir pour las pour le théâtre
j'ai de l'espoir pour les terres puisque
j'ai de l'espoir pour l'homme
je pense pas que que de christophe que
ce soit venu en vain on y voit parfois
dans les théâtres les spectateurs sont
un peu plus âgés des noms s'est passé
est-ce que penser que c'est un genre qui
le théâtre ne mourra jamais autant la
télévision le cinéma peut mourir peut
disparaître peut être transformé mais on
aura toujours besoin du vivant face aux
vivants et puis le théâtre il a les
moyens de faire du théâtre sont quand
même
très faible on peut monter il suffit
d'un petit très tôt un petit machin de
comédiens qui rasait sans rien du tout
et moi je montre les spectacles sont des
corps le plus souvent j'essaye de 2,2
les bons et ça c'est intangible ça ne
mourra pas parce que votre passion alors
ensuite c'est le problème de l'être
humain qui va devenir l'être humain dans
le on aura toujours besoin du miroir on
a toujours besoin que que qui est le
microcosme du macrocosme du monde cc
c'est essentiel pour comprendre le monde
et pour toucher l'homme dans sarlat le
cinéma c'est le problème de l'image
l'image et elle peut être lointaine elle
peut être trafiquées elle peut être en
bois bien manipuler elle peut être bon
tandis que le théâtre vous on est là
vous êtes là présent nous vivons et puis
le théâtre il est extraordinaire parce
que c'est parce que le spectateur est
créateur par sa présence on le sait nous
qui joue 10 mais elle est bien sûr
chaque soir le spectacle différent pas
seulement parce que votre
femme a pu vous trompez lundi que vous
n'êtes pas contents ça juste un peu joué
aussi ou parce que vous venez d'avoir un
enfant et que vous êtes ravi mais aussi
parce que ça peut arriver à chaque
spectateur qui est en face et
là la présence du spectateur elle vous
aide à réaliser ce que ce que ce que
j'appelle liposthey c'est à dire 7 cette
plénitude entre le 100% hommes et 100 %
personnage donc c'est ça c'est ça qui
fait que miracle là c'est ce miracle a
mené ce miracle l'ipad perturbé par
beaucoup de choses si vous avez un
spectateur qui tous au premier rang ça
vous est difficile de ne pas rester
jean-luc jane eyre qui essaye d'avoir
détruit et je sais de quoi je parle et
puis à côté de ça alors que si vous êtes
si vous avez une tension une
à côté ça une écoute une cd rom vous
pouvez vous perdre dans le personnage et
ça devient unique magique extraordinaire
et c'est la clint sortes d'expériences
qui existent quoi merci infiniment
sélectionné alors je dis aux
téléspectateurs parvenaient à venet à
versailles aux petites écuries voilà
vous les voir cette passion du théâtre
vous accueillez merci infiniment merci